OK, Manuel says, using Ahrefs, are the numbers similar to SEMrush?
Or is it it?
They're going to be different.
So Manuel's asking, are the numbers, really the question is,
are the numbers on different tools the same?
No.
OK, you're going to have to use whatever tool you want to use.
If you want to use Ahrefs, awesome.
Doesn't matter.
You've got to get that baseline, right?
You've got to figure out what is that magic number that you can go off of.
It's going to be different for SEMrush.
It's going to be different for Ahrefs.
It's going to be different for Mangools.
It's going to be different for Keyword Planner.
You've got to find that baseline.
So no, they're going to be it's going to be different.